this was a big story it came in last
evening from western russia an explosion
ripping through a public bus killing two
women that figure went up just last hour
it was one notes two and injuring 17
others in the western russian city of
veronica warning this report coming up
starts with street camera footage of the
actual explosion and contains some
distressing images thereafter so
a split second before the explosion bump
and then debris flying out from all
sides and then the fire at the time it's
believed the bus had around 35
passengers aboard as the blast hit many
of those still able to move dazed don't
know what's happened try to flee
followed by more disturbing images of
the explosion showing an injured person
lying on the ground there don't know the
severity doesn't look good hope they're
okay among the debris russia's
investigative committee has opened a
criminal probe into the explosion with a
number of explanations still being
considered but so far it's a mystery
one eyewitness told us what he saw
i was driving towards the southwest
marketplace and drove by the bus a blast
suddenly happened my car was shaken i
looked in the rearview mirror and saw
that my vehicle had been pierced by an
explosion i stopped the bus's roof was
blown away people started arriving
emergency services police firemen
someone was taken away with their legs
blown off others had severe abrasions
the explosion was very loud so loud i
was deafened for some time and the blast
pressure was so high that my car was
almost pushed to the other side of the
road
well our correspondence there donald
caught in the city of veronica dawn
morning um you're at the scene of course
there's little there to tell us about
the horror that happened last night's
been cleared away as best i can but
still a big mystery surrounding what
happened yeah
hi there kevin like you said yeah i'm on
site where this tragedy took place this
explosion on thursday night
as you're going to be able to see soon
as soon as these buses get out of the
way
most of what's left of the explosion has
already been cleared out but as you can
see over here behind me there are some
flowers that have been laid at the bench
of the bus station that people laid
overnight in memory of those who died in
this tragedy
as for what caused this this explosion
there are a number of theories the main
one comes
from the investigative committee that's
looking into what happened it says that
either this diesel bus was fueled with
the wrong fuel or it was the result of a
gas cylinder explosion on board some
were also saying that it could have been
due to the negligence of the driver
while the police have already said that
an earlier theory that it was a
terrorist attack is at this point deemed
unlikely
projectiles such as pieces of wire or
nails things usually used in explosive
devices were not found those injured
were mostly harmed by fragments of
flying glass however the chance that it
could be an explosive device can still
not be ruled out
now when the bus exploded every seat on
board was filled that was a total of 35
people on board according to the
region's governor 19 people were injured
and another two were killed with one
woman tragically having her legs blown
off
in the explosion it was a brutal sight
as we later heard from the driver's
description of what happened
we were at the store people were getting
on the bus the traffic light turned red
people got on from the crosswalk i
started driving off then the blast
happened broken glass smoke i couldn't
understand what happened people helped
to evacuate others there are people who
are seriously injured
now shortly after this tragedy took
place the regional uh governor of the
veronese region called for a full
inspection of the transport vehicles
that are there that can that uh
inspection has since concluded and it
found no problems with any other
vehicles uh involved so the
investigation is still going on of
course into what exactly caused this
explosion and we'll bring our viewers
all the details about this tragedy as
they become available
you